i have some footage here of one of the
most exciting moments in sports history
and to make it even more exciting the
commentator is speaking in german and
i'm assuming that this is okay under
fair use because i'm really using it for
a a math problem but i want you to watch
this video and then i'll ask you a
question about it
so you see it's exciting in any language
that you might watch it but my question
to you
is how fast was usain bolt going what
was his average speed when he ran that
hundred meters right there and i
encourage you to watch the video as many
times as you need to do it and now i'll
give you a little bit of time to think
about it and then we will solve it
so we needed to figure out how fast was
usain bolt going over the 100 meters so
we're really thinking about in the case
of this problem average speed or average
rate and you might already be familiar
with the notion that distance
distance
is equal to
rate or speed i'll just write rate times
time and i could write times like that
but once we start doing algebra the
traditional multiplication symbol can
seem very confusing because it looks
just like the variable x so instead i
will write times like this so distance
is equal to rate times
is equal to rate times time and
hopefully this makes some intuitive
sense for you if your rate or your speed
were 10 meters per second just as an
example that's not necessarily how fast
he went but if you went 10 meters per
second and if you were to do that for
for two seconds for two seconds
seconds
then it should hopefully make intuitive
sense that you went 20 meters you went
10 meters per second for 2 seconds and
it also works out mathematically 10
times 2 is equal to 20 and then you have
seconds in the denominator and seconds
up here in the numerator i just wrote
seconds here with an s i wrote it out
there but they also cancel out and
you're just left with the u the units of
meters so you're just left with 20
meters so hopefully this makes intuitive
sense with that out of the way let's
actually think about let's actually
think about the problem the problem at
hand what information do we actually
have so we do we have the distance
so what is
what is
the distance in the video we just did
and i'll give you a second or two
to think about it
well this race was 100 meters so the
distance was
100 meters now what else do we know do
we know well we're trying to figure out
the rate that's what we're going to
figure out what else do we know out of
out of this expression out of this
equation right over here well do we know
the time
do we know the time what was the time
that it took usain bolt to run the
hundred meters and i'll give you another
few seconds to think about that
well luckily they were timing the whole
thing and they not and they also showed
that it's a it's a world record but this
right over here is in seconds it's how
long it took usain bolt to run the 100
meters it was 9.589.58
seconds and i'll just write s for
seconds so given this information here
what you need to attempt to do is now
give us our rate in terms of meters per
second i want you to think if you can
figure out the rate in terms of meters
per second we know the distance and we
know the time
well let's substitute these values into
this equation right over here we know
the distance is 100 meters
the distance
is 100 meters and it's equal to we don't
know the rate so i'll just write rate
right over here let's see again let me
write in that same color it's equal to
rate
rate times and what's the time we do
know the time it's 9.58 seconds
9.58
9.58 seconds and we care about rate we
care about solving for rate so how can
we do that
well if you look at this right hand side
of the equation i have 9.58 seconds
times rate if i were able to divide this
right hand side by 9.58 seconds i'll
just have rate on the right hand side
and that's what i want to solve for so
you say well wait why don't i just
divide the right hand side by 9.58
seconds
9.58
seconds because if i did that the nine
the if the units cancel out if we're
doing dimensional analysis don't worry
too much if that word doesn't make sense
to you but the units cancel out and the
9.58 cancel out but i can't just divide
one side of an equation by a number when
we start off this is equal to this up
here if i divide it if i divide the
right side by 9.58 in order for the
equality to still be true i need to
divide the left side by the same thing
so i can't just divide the right side i
have to divide the left side in order
for the equality to still be true if i
said one thing is equal to another thing
and i divide the other thing by
something in order for them to still be
equal i have to divide the first thing
by that same amount so i divide by 9.58
seconds so on our right hand side and
this was the whole point these two
cancel out
and then on the left hand side i'm left
with 100 divided by 9.58 and my units
are meters per second which are the
exact units that i want for rate or for
speed and so let's get the calculator
out to divide 100 by 9.58
so i've got
100 meters
divided by 9.58
seconds
it gives me 10 point let's see we get
about three significant digits here so
let's say 10.4
so this gives us 10.4 and i'll write in
the rate color
10.4 and the units are meters per second
meters
per second is equal to
is equal to
my rate now the next question so we got
this in meters per second but
unfortunately meters per second is
they're not the you know when we drive a
car we don't see the the speedometer in
meters per second we see that either
kilometers per hour or miles per hour so
the next task i i have for you is to
express this speed or this rate and this
is his average speed or his average rate
over the 100 meters but to think about
this in terms of kilometers per hour
kilometers per hour so try to figure out
if you can if you can rewrite this in
kilometers per hour
well let's just take this step by step
so i'm going to write so let me just go
down here start over so i started off
with
10.4 and i'll write meters in blue
meters in blue and seconds
seconds
in magenta
now
we want to get to kilometers per hour
right now meters per second so let's
take baby steps let's first think about
it in terms of kilometers per second and
i'll give you a second to think about
what we would do to this to turn this
into kilometers per second
well the intuition here if i'm going
10.4 meters per second how many how many
kilometers is 10.4 meters well a
kilometers is a much larger unit of
measurement it's a thousand times larger
so 10.4 meters will be a much smaller
number of kilometers and in particular
i'm going to divide by a thousand
another way to think about it if you
want to focus on the units we want to
get rid of this meters and we want to
kilometers so we want a kilometers
and we want to get rid of these meters
so if we had a meters in the numerator
we could divide by meters here and they
would cancel out but the intuitive way
to think about it is we're going from a
smaller unit meters to a larger unit
kilometers so 10.4 meters are going to
be a much smaller number of kilometers
but if we look at it this way how many
how many meters are in one kilometer one
kilometer is equal to
one thousand meters this right over here
one kilometer over a thousand meters is
over one over one where cent we're not
changing the fundamental value we're
essentially just multiplying it by one
but when we do this
when we do this what do we get well the
meters cancel out we're left with
kilometers and seconds and the numbers
you get 10.4 divided by a thousand 10.4
divided by a thousand is going to give
you so if you divide by 10 you're going
to get 1.04 you divide by 100 you get
0.104 you divide by a thousand you get
0.0104
so that's just 10.4 divided by a
thousand and then our units are
kilometers
kilometers per second so that's the
kilometers and then i have my seconds
right over here
now so let me write the equal sign now
let's try to convert this to kilometers
per hour and i'll give you a little bit
of time to think about that one
well hours there's there's 3600 seconds
in an hour so however many kilometers i
do in a second i'm going to do 3 600
times that in an hour and the units will
also work out if i'm going i'm right now
well if i do this many in a second so
it's going to be times 3 600
there are 3 600 seconds in an hour 3 600
seconds in an hour another way to think
about it is we want hours in the
denominator we had seconds so if we
multiply by seconds per hour there are 3
600 seconds per hour the seconds are
going to cancel out and we're going to
be left with hours in the denominator so
seconds cancel out and we're left with
kilometers per hour but now we have to
multiply this number times 3 600 i'll
get the calculator out for that
i'll get the calculator out for that so
we have we have .0104
.0104 times 3600 3600
gives us 37 point i'll just say 37.4
so this is equal to 37.4
37.4 kilometers
kilometers
kilometers per hour
per hour so that's his average speed in
kilometers per hour and now the last
thing i want to do for those of you for
those of us in america will convert into
imperial units or sometimes called
english units which are ironically not
necessarily used in uk they tend to be
used in america
so let's convert this into miles per
hour and the one thing i will tell you
just in case you don't know is that
their 1.61
kilometers
is equal to
is equal to 1 mile so i'll give you a
little bit of time to convert this into
miles per hour
well as you see from this a mile is a
slightly larger or reasonably larger
unit than a kilometer so if you're going
37.4 kilometers in a certain amount of
time you're going to go a slightly
smaller amount of miles in a certain
amount of time or in particular you're
going to divide by 1.61
so let me rewrite it if i have
37.4 kilometers per hour
kilometers per hour
we're going to a larger unit we're going
to miles so we're gonna divide by
something larger than one so we have one
we have one let me write it in blue
one mile
one mile is equal to
is equal to 1.61 kilometers
or you could say there's one 1.61 mile
per kilometer it also once again works
out with units we want to get rid of the
kilometers in the numerator so we would
want it in the denominator and we want a
mile in the numerator so that's why we
have a mile in the numerator here so
let's once again multiply or i guess in
this case we're dividing by 1.61 and we
get
so we get let's just divide our previous
value by 1.61
1.61 and we get 23 point i'll just round
up 23.3
this is equal to 23.3
20 23
23.3
and then we have miles
miles
miles per hour
20 miles per hour which is obviously
very fast he's the fastest human but
it's not maybe as fast as you might have
imagined you know in a car 23.3 miles
per hour doesn't seem so fast and
especially relative to the animal world
it's not particularly noteworthy this is
actually slightly slower than a charging
elephant charging elephants have been
clocked at 25 miles per hour